welcome to this video playing Grand
Master cruel mania where's that Gil
popular ski what Bishop a three are you
drunk that looks funny okay there kids
it's not not so bad that it immediately
can be can be punished but well it looks
pretty weird a game so what now here
Bishop to d6 well that's probably a
simple way to do it
ok
you're not recapturing that looks
strange disconnected or something nope
yeah maybe one of those things that
happen to me at a time people getting at
the door or whatever during the games
okay cannot take you 5 27 as a double
attack okay that's interesting
interesting here can take take away the
night to speed up my development quite a
bit so I'm going to do that
yeah no yeah I can screen takes just for
quick quick development wasn't sure
about Bishop c4 because what exactly now
yeah but I can go if for that looks
pretty nice for black so Bishop g4 or is
there a better move even I can go 93
actually that's check that will irritate
them you cannot even take it what where
do you go where do you go with your
night buddy you have no square white
resigns yep you have no square okay so
much for the rang a tang also call
Sookie opening yeah Bishop e3 that that
looks strange really strange um yeah
okay Bishop b2 as normal or a three we
should be towards what they're mostly
playing and then I'm going to take this
black black gets a slight advantage all
of this opening not much but he gets a
comfortable slight advantage this is
just as before it's not a good opening
but that's really weird okay a5 was
already interesting but why not why not
just develop cannot be bad okay got some
lag here should be sexy for you know all
looks normal
yeah okay cannot take because of that
double attack do idea you went yeah and
I don't know I mean there's doesn't look
right yeah why give me this development
with 96 it's not so easy to give white
some advice I understand but I mean
black is just better with the center but
still I don't know what that helps Jim
okay Queen cheeks and don't really know
if could Bishop c4 is a good idea at a
computer is already very pessimistic
gives me minus one already it just
better developed I have things to attack
porn porn itís loose and no coordination
okay this this you went back in queen
bee three there's also a four and now
this is an interesting move very
difficult not to suggest something for
wider lose this immediately jump okay
went back here here here went back check
check and okay us to go king of one and
play that position probably I don't know
Bishop somewhere probably 87 m not
somewhere yeah and this is not great
after Uxie aid we should pay for these
kind of ideas black has a big initiative
and white has lost canceling rights but
yeah it's what he has to do this is just
blundering a piece okay well thanks for
watching